starting today with the brief correction
every once in a while I do have to make
one last week during a segment where I
was pointing out that Bernie Sanders
having a million dollars is not a huge
deal for someone his age statistically I
reversed the mean and the median net
worth numbers
Bernie has mean net worth for someone
his age not median but the broader
analysis about this not being an
outrageous amount of money for someone
who is close to 80 years old and whether
it's relevant to his policies the
analysis still stands but I do want to
correct my reading of that chart in last
week's story there's been more and more
discussion lately about something we've
been talking about for a long time on
the show actually which is that Donald
Trump is horrible but in the end he's
really a symptom of the disease that is
ruining the United States and that
allowed him to become president in the
first place because if there was no such
disease Donald Trump never could have
gotten elected and we wouldn't even be
having the problems that we're having
right now as a result of his presidency
and if I had to sort of like name or
describe or qualify this disease I would
encapsulate it as rampant right-wing
thinking reactionary social and economic
politics emboldened and empowered by
growing wealth and influence inequality
which favors the rich and corporations
and that kind of sums up a lot of the
individual policy issues that we've been
talking about for a very very long time
at this point but if there's one thing
that I can sort of repeat and repeat and
repeat which i think is worthy of
repeating it's that while the problem is
a reactionary right-wing slide in terms
of who's in charge in the United States
both the Republican and Democratic
parties are part of the problem but I'm
not saying they are equal parts of the
problem and sort of playing the it's
equally bad on both sides both sides ISM
because I don't do that I don't think
it's right and I want to be clear that
that's not what I'm doing so on the
Republican side the Republican Party has
become more extreme than ever science no
longer matters the facts no longer
matter the law no longer matters and the
concept of a double standard or
of hypocrisy as something that might
even sort of interest right-wingers is
laughable at this point in time we see
it with the debt and deficit I've talked
about it ad nauseam I won't talk about
it again a Bill Clinton excoriated for a
consensual affair Donald Trump accused
of sexual assault by more than a dozen
women becomes President of the United
States Trump will fix the trade deficit
actually increases it to record numbers
with China but who cares anyway it
doesn't even really matter
Trump has multiple affairs and wives and
divorces evangelicals say yeah but he's
better than Hillary and he's against
abortion or at least he claims to be and
we believe him climate change it's a
hoax who cares about our planet anyway
and this is all actually sadly a logical
conclusion to the right-wing slide that
we've seen in the Republican Party
dating back to the 1990s you could even
say actually that it goes back to Reagan
but it was sort of imagined it kind of
being birthed under Reagan but becoming
strong and more adult in the 1990s under
Bill Clinton which really gave this
movement oxygen the Republican Party has
moved outrageously to the right dating
back to the Clinton era corporate media
has helped them do it by not properly
covering this outrageous right-wing
slide so Trump's a major problem
Trump's disgusting but it's the endpoint
of what Republicans have been building
for the last 20 years 20 years of
talking points instead of actually
thinking about stuff talking points like
low taxes no abortion of religion being
allowed to control and influence
government spreading democracy via the
military which by the way is older than
twenty years but it's been used a lot in
the last 2025 years by Republicans don't
worry about the planet and climate
change and whether it's 20 years or
really more like 35 the idolization of
celebrity over intellectualism and
actual thinking is one of the biggest
aspects of this disease 20 plus years of
straight up saying higher education is
indoctrination 20 straight years of
being proud about not being educated and
informed and just believing what Fox &
Friends
or Bill O'Reilly previously or Rush
Limbaugh for decades have been telling
them 20 years of sort of hammering away
at the idea that the entire media is
liberal and only a few sources which I
already named are going to tell you the
truth and the endpoint is obviously for
someone like Donald Trump who is both a
symptom of the disease and a catalyst
for more of the disease to be President
of the United States now you might hear
me say this and you you could accurately
say but David hold on a lot of more
traditional Republicans don't like
Donald Trump doesn't matter the point is
they participated in allowing the
disease to fester which led to someone
like Donald Trump being a lept electable
by the Republican voters and it becomes
a self-reinforcing feedback loop where
20 years of this what I call it
weaponized ignorant leads to Trump and
then Trump makes them feel many of them
like they won which I fear will lead to
more Trump and things like Trump and
then where the Democrats fit back into
this is that both Democrats and
Republicans allowed the economic system
to continue in a direction that makes
all of this more acute both Democrats
and Republicans have participated in
allowing this system to grow income
inequality and to grow wealth inequality
to not nearly strongly enough regulate
the form of capitalism that we have
Democrats only somewhat standing in the
way of Republican military campaigns
around the world and again this is not
both sides ISM on issues Americans more
and more agree with Democrats period
every study tells us this we're going to
talk about that later in the week
it's the Republican Party that has
carried out this massive multi-decade
campaign of gaslighting and influence
peddling and slowly pushing away from
actual democracy because on the issues
they are running out of voters and then
when you add to this the benefit of
gerrymandering which we've talked about
because the censuses have been
conveniently timed to allow them to
do that you add to that control of the
courts most recently the Supreme Court
which Donald Trump has been an
incredibly useful operator to now get
them decades more control of the Supreme
Court and what you very quickly realize
is that unless the left gets it together
immediately I'm talking like tomorrow
they've left has to get it together
tomorrow and I'm gonna talk in the next
segment about the Russia issue related
to this it's over for 2020 and we are
going to see many many more years of
this